gilbert collard député européen du
rassemblement national
[Musique]
bonjour gilbert collard merci beaucoup
d'être avec king ce matin en direct sur
rt france votre réaction tout d'abord à
l'ouverture de ces vaccinodromes avec
cette volte face de la stratégie
vaccinale en france et la mise à
contribution de l'armée avec cinq
centres qui vont ouvrir cette semaine
est ce que c est ce que c est ce qu on
est en bonne voie de résoudre ce
problème de vaccination selon vous
constat que vous avez fait sur lequel je
veux revenir parce qu'il a son utilité
c'est que monsieur verront que c'est pas
le monsieur santé de gouvernance et de
monsieur girouette de la santé du
gouvernement 1
un jour c'est oui le lendemain c'est non
lenox hill aux roms il n'y croyait pas
maintenant il est il va au maximum comme
le croyant va à lourdes
donc il faut quand même je crois
souligné c'est servir mme en permanence
et variations permanente de monsieur
vers ambre on a des vaccinodromes mais
on a pas de vaccin on est donc dans une
situation kafkaïenne c'est comme si on
avait des gars est pas train des
hippodromes et pas de chevaux bon c'est
un peu
loufoque les chaudraies et voudrait
qu'on ait beaucoup de vaccins et moines
vaccine rome que beaucoup de
vaccinodromes et pas de vaccin
l'important c'est quand même de réussir
à avoir et des vaccins et les lieux de
vaccination
hélas hélas sur le déplore premiers mois
très très très sincèrement les vaccins
manque voilà la question est là il faut
aussi se rappeler que les lits de
réanimation manque et c'est ce qui fait
problème c'est ce qui fait qu'on ait
aujourd'hui confinée parce que les
promesses doute et de mars sauf erreur
de ma part du ministre de la santé la
création de lits de réanimation n'ont
pas été tenues il faut le rappeler il
faut le rappeler il faut le rappeler
alors que ce gouvernement disposés à
compter du déclenchement funès de la
pandémie d'un an pour s'organiser et
s'équiper et en un an nous n'avons pas
obtenu les lits de réanimation et
l'information rapide possible des
personnels tout tout tout le drame de la
pandémie en grande partie est liée au
fait qu' on n'a pas les lits de
réanimation suffisant et que on risque
d'en arriver à faire ce tri horrible si
la pandémie n'est pas jugulée
on n'en est pas encore là levée des
mesures de ces quatre semaines de
confinement on l'appelle comme on veut
c'est pas vraiment un confinement
gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement s'est dit optimiste sur une
issue dans monde en quatre semaines
écouter les mesures ont été annoncées
pour quatre semaines avec l'objectif
qu'elle fonctionne et je crois
profondément qu'elles vont fonctionner
je vois des français conscients que la
situation est difficile qui font très
attention qui respecte les règles
on commence à voir des signaux qui
peuvent rendre optimiste tout ça
encourage à maintenir nos efforts alors
on a vu les français réagir dans la
première partie de cette matinale il n'y
croit pas vraiment est ce que vous vous
y croyez à cette issue à la mi-mai comme
l'a annoncé le chef de l'état comment
les croire
comment les croire depuis depuis
l'apparition de pandémie
ils nous ont tellement tellement menti
rappelez-vous au tout début c'était
inutile de porter des masques
c'était mal à mme buzyn qui le disaient
rappelez vous c'était d'une grippette
avec un peu d'aspirine ans pourrait
lutter contre elle rappelez-vous
l'absence de blood sur hbo dans les
hôpitaux on a égrainé toutes les toutes
les toutes les bêtises qui ont pu être
dit on n'en sait rien si dans quatre
semaines on pourra sortir du confinement
il faut accorder les lits de réanimation
de telle façon qu'on puisse faire face
un pic pandémique et prêter toutes les
personnes qui en ont besoin à l'hôpital
voilà maintenant lucia talent c'est pas
madame irma et il ne sait pas ce qui se
passera dans quatre semaines pas plus
que moi pas plus que vous on est
dépendant de tellement de facteurs
tellement de variation de tellement
d'évolution que la seule solution c'est
d'abord la thérapeutique
on en parle pratiquement plus du
traitement de la thérapeutique et
ensuite l'équipement des hôpitaux en
matériel et en hommes
ça c'est rassurant ça c'est rassurant à
mort la clé également ce sont les
gaullistes et les fameuses autotests ci
a annoncé par le gouvernement qui seront
finalement disponibles pas avant le 12
avril et plus en grande surface comme
initialement annoncé alors que c'est le
cas dans d'autres pays d'europe
qu'en pensez vous les gens pensent poser
la question c'est apporter la réponse
dande d'abord là encore on a un retard à
l'allumage les tests arrivent par
rapport à beaucoup d'autres pays en
retard
ensuite ils sont mis à disposition un
peu partout dans beaucoup beaucoup de
pays
et ici ça ne sera pas possible parce
qu'il ya le poids des lobbys on est on
est un pays qui est ligotée par
la multiplication des intérêts
personnels et des lobbys en est on est
on est on est on est pris en étau entre
une bureau technocratie maladive
tatillonne jalouse de ses pouvoirs et
des puissances c'est l'économie qui
veulent faire leurs peurs sur le malheur
des gens voilà on y arrive on n'arrive
pas à s'en sortir parce que ces lobbys
et sept bureaux technocratie sentant
relais avec les hommes du pouvoir parce
que ses hommes du pouvoir sorte ou de la
bureau technocratie ou des lobbys votre
réaction gilbert collard au dîner que
l'on destin mondains organisés dans la
capitale si des ministres étaient mises
en cause devraient être démissionnés
ah ça me paraîtrait vraiment salutaire
parce qu'on ne peut pas d'un côté comme
on l'a vu envoyer une dizaine de
gendarmes ce qui est vraiment ridicule
sur une plage pour interpellé à un père
de famille avec ses enfants et deux amis
qui mange un pique-niqué qui boivent un
verre de rosé pour leur infliger 450
euros damende c'est à dire le prix d'un
repas dans ce fameux restaurant
clandestins et laisser faire les
ministres intègres qui on souhaite comme
dans ruy blas bon appétit il faut qu'on
ait il faut qu'on ait les résultats de
l' enquête afin de savoir dans quel sens
et quels sont ces goinfres qui pendant
que que que l'ensemble de la population
est soumise à restrictions et punitions
amanda attestation vendre dans le temps
dans le mépris du partage du fardeau
tout simplement ces deux mais plus parce
que vous pensez qu'on saura qui étaient
présents ministre ou pas je pense que
les enquêteurs vont serein un plaisir
d'enquêté et des journalistes qui seront
forcément renseigné par les enquêteurs
se faire un plaisir de le dire on a déjà
des noms qui circulent un bon nepad et
on n'est pas complètement désinformer
mais tant qu'on n'a pas de preuves on
n'a pas le droit c'est normal du reste
de prononcer d'articuler de murmurer il
ya des photos qui circulent aussi sur
sur les réseaux sociaux envoie ministre
qui serait au pied du restaurant parle
de 2,2 de l'immeuble de la rue vivienne
mais bon tant que l' enquête n'a pas dit
si c'est fondé ou pas prudence on verra
pour l'instant c'est un secret pour pas
grand monde dans le monde politique
alors on va s'abstenir pour l'instant on
va attendre les conclusions de l'enquêté
évidemment beaucoup d'eau de parisiens
s'indigne de la propreté de la ville de
paris il ya un état qui circule beaucoup
sur les réseaux sociaux le hashtag
saccage paris beaucoup d'élus également
à l'instar de marine le pen regarder les
milliers dimanche partagé avec le
hashtag saccage paris brise le coeur des
amoureux de paris bravo aux parisiens
révolte et la dégradation de notre si
belle capitale par l'équipe hidalgo est
une souffrance nationale qui ne doit
laisser aucun français en différents
alors beaucoup de parisiens s'indigner
la mairie faryal dénoncé une campagne de
dénigrement de la droite est ce que
c'est le cas non non non non non c'est
vrai c'est un ami nalco dépotoir paris
est devenue suffit d'y circuler l'idée
ambühl est un dépotoir c'est une ville
qui était à l'abandon de nombreuses
photographies
circulent qui montrent l'état d'abandon
de de la ville c c'est inconcevable que
la capitale de la france ce monument
urbain en chasse et de 2,2 de trésors
historiques visuel poétique artistique
soit à ce point balafré salies dès
l'après luxe et c'est vraiment une une
forme de de détestation de son pays que
de laisser aller à cet état de
délabrement la capitale la république en
marche à 5 ans d'existence
aujourd'hui quel constat faites vous
pour ce parti présidentiel qui n'a pas
su je le rappelle sont créés localement
je ne savais pas tout avait 5 ans
d'existence
cc c'est vous qui me gêne pas la vague
et je croyais qu'il n'avait jamais
existé mais enfin bon
quand j'étais quand j'étais au parlement
que j'ai quitté un peu parce que la
fréquentation des députés dans marx
était insupportable s'était jamais on
n'avait jamais vu ça j'ai même vu dans
l'hémicycle rendez vous compte des
députés dans marche applaudir un député
avant qu'il parle
à tel point que le député en question on
à l'archi bien sûr a été obligé de le
redire mais attendez que je parle pour
applaudir qu'on a on a en a un parlement
d'automates ccc c'est pas un mouvement
la république en marche c'est une espèce
de de club med c'est une espèce de
rendez-vous des golfeurs
c'est pas un mouvement politique c'est
un mouvement associatif d'intérêt de
gens qui s'ennuient récents se l'est qui
ont trouvé en s'inscrivant sur sur
internet à des formulaires l'occasion de
faire une présence politique mais pas de
la politique ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
du reste on a un état de délabrement de
la démocratie qu'est kéké qui
hallucinant la démocratie a quitté le
parlement le parlement ne pas
le plus c'est dramatique car je vraiment
c'est une eux c'est une une
autodestruction de l'expression
démocratique qui est dû à la nullité
d'un mouvement politique
merci beaucoup gilbert collard d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt france